oh discouraged by the pandemic
two-time corporate trustee champions and
foreign in this
online air will any team rise on the
occasion
and knock them off their heads find out
[Music]
oh hello there welcome to the 2020
season of the corporate chess league i'm
alex kirford founder of the corporate
chess league
financial advisor and team captain of
edward jones
we are so happy that you are making the
adjustment to
virtual online corporate chess league
this year
and so happy to have more teams more
players and more competition when we
started out the corporate chess league
we desired to have an opportunity for
networking
enjoyment of the game of chess and being
able
to come together and compete as
different companies glad that you're
here with us
today and looking forward to more games
to come
now i want to turn it over to mike who's
going to explain
the format and the rules for this year
hello welcome to the corporate chess
league
this is the fourth installment out of
six
and we got some great players playing
tonight
and some great corporations i will give
you guys the uh the rundown
and the current standings so they are
playing for grand
prix points and the top
four scoring teams at the end of the
season get to play in the final four
december 17th 2020.
so here are the current standings edward
jones
has amassed 180
and a half grand prix points
they win every single time as they said
nobody can really
knock them down so maybe tonight maybe
not
and number two is merits with 101
wwt has 83 points
enterprise 78 and a half points
so if the final four started today
that would be the final four right
behind is ascension with 72 and a half
bear has 68 express scripts 59
and doherty 18 and a half points so how
do you
accumulate these grand three points
so every game that you're uh
that somebody wins in the corporation
they get
one point if your team ends up winning
the match
they will get an additional 20 grand
pre points this is a double round
meaning you play the same opponent from
your opposing corporation twice
one with the white pieces one with the
black pieces
and then you then you play match two or
round two
as there'll be another double round and
that will start
approximately a little bit before seven
o'clock
so if you win your bonus games too you
also get uh you know one point so
so if a team brought uh like 10 players
you can get a whole lot of points you
could get
uh 40 points for that round
so that's how you accumulate the points
and let's see
some uh let's see some games so
it's a game in 10
no delay no increment game 10.
so let's jump right into the action they
started about
5-10 minutes ago so they are into the
games and let's check out
the founder of uh the
corporate chess league alex crawford's
game he is
currently according to the computer up
20 points
but that can be deceiving but let's
check out the action
he has plus 13 on the board
and the matchups for tonight round one
is uh edward jones is playing
enterprise enterprise
chose not to bring their three heavy
hitters tonight
so enterprise is the underdog in this
match
for sure alex crawford is playing
board two in this matchup
so what is going on it looks like alex
is up a queen
so he's got a queen and his opponent
doesn't so that's always a good sign so
it looks like
alex is gonna take game number one
we do have a result on the board already
essentia playing board one for
bear has beat merits's
board one maybe swap
so hopefully they'll they're often
running with uh
with game two and it looks like essentia
is having his way again
accenture with a a high rating
uh chess expert on chess.com these are
chess.com blitz ratings
they're playing with so let's see oh
he's got a big fork on the board
the night fork so he's you know the
double attack so he's got to bring his
queen
back here to protect the rook at least
they'll get
an exchange
but it still says he'll be plus
32. oh because he's got this big chuck
coming at you
and then that'll be all she wrote
now king taker1324 he also plays for
edward jones
he got the best game prize last month
he had a very exciting one so let's see
how he's doing
he is playing the the white pieces it
looks like
and uh he is playing enterprises
board three and it looks like he's doing
very well he's got this rook
in a pin bishop a3 let's see why he
played there
it'd be nice if somehow we could attack
this rook some more but
he doesn't he didn't want his bishop to
get captured so it looks like this is a
natural move right now bishop to c4
let's see if uh kingtaker1324
can find it so there are eight
corporations tonight
the the big matchups we have merits
against bear
ascension versus express scripts wwt
against doherty and edward jones against
enterprise those are the the
four matchups for this round one is it
is a double round
that means you play one with the white
pieces one with the black pieces against
the same opponent
and then we'll start match two uh
later on
so instead he decided to give him a
check
um
well he does have this extra piece so
he'll be doing okay
now uh this guy
21 from enterprise he might have dreams
of playing
f3 followed by queen takes g2 mate
so let's see if let's see if he can get
his dream to come true here
oh david chapman he plays in the friday
action quiets from time to time
we actually do have in-person friday
action quads believe it or not
they're limited to eight people the time
control has been uh reduced
and there's one spot left so call the
chess club if you want to get in
it's at six o'clock tomorrow
so david chapman plays for
[Music]
plays for wwt so they they're on the
board
and yeah and wwt is planned doherty
wwt did not show up last last month
this is of course the fourth installment
out of six
in order to get into the final four in
in uh december
but they still held on they were they
were second place
uh going into uh
going into uh the the third installment
but they did slip
up merits merits overtook them the
idol wwt but they are still currently in
that
final four position you want to be on
the left side of the screen not the
white side
because if you're on the the right side
of the screen that means you're you will
not be invited to the final four
and as i said edward jones has won every
single time one time it went down to
armageddon against
enterprise but alex corford the founder
of the corporate chess league came up
really big
and uh and won for his team and they are
back-to-back champions
this is this is year three of the uh
corporate chess league
and they've they got their name on the
square they get a a nice big
board with their uh with their
company logo on it and it says
back-to-back champs edward jones 18 19.
so 2020. just because they accumulate
all that all those points
that really does not give them any kind
of edge in the
final four
so if you if you make it to the final
four it's anybody's
anybody's game so let's see what's going
on
in this one h6 yeah just go away knight
and then you can successfully castle
probably
unless he wants to get creative i
wouldn't i just go back to
just go back to knight f3 and then
castle
what is this guy thinking about is he
thinking about going for it
yes i am still here i'm still here
that looks like knight f3
it has yet to be played on the board
maybe this guy is trying to be creative
the gentleman from doherty
oh it okay okay this is the live
position now just just as they go okay
let's check around let's go back to uh
to alex
crawford playing uh board two
for edward jones he's playing moneyball
in
alex did win the first one you know he
was up uh he
had a huge lead he had the queen so
let's see how he's doing this time
around
it looks like it's a way more even game
the computer
has a slight advantage when it gives
them a check
so yeah that's how yep just king h-a
just get out of dodge yep oh and alex is
threatening the big rook is he going to
take it
it was played it was on the board
how did the computer
oh well that's why he couldn't play it
his his
his queen was under attack smart man
smart man alex
you can't fool alex so now
he's got to get this rook out of the way
somehow some way
where would you want your rook to go
maybe e8
just protect the pawn
maybe this is the live position it is a
i mean the only other alternative really
is f6
you're one well i want that so i just go
to e8 oh we got we got
uh oh we have a we have a checkmate on
the board
for uh the board one of
enterprise jt
knock on wood won the first game against
big daddy jazz 64. so so let's see the
rematch
the board one action yeah as i said
enterprise left there uh three big
heavy hitters home today
so they might not
they might not perform and so that gives
all the other teams that are right
behind
enterprise a chance to uh to catch up
because enterprise is just barely
holding on to that fourth spot
and uh the next the next
uh the fifth installment of the
corporate chess league
will be october 15th thursday october
15th
so maybe they can they can bring them
all that day and
and reclaim their spot if they if they
so lose it
ascension has a big round two match
against wwt
in round two tonight so they they might
be able to jump in
that that spot if things go well for
ascension
so white got castled
jd asked the knight to politely move
is he going to have dreams of a grandeur
i don't think oh where where else are
you gonna go
oh are you oh oh that
that that is on the board that is on the
board
so there there is a best game award
so maybe they're just going for it you
know they have such a
huge advantage they're they're number
one they they're
they're almost doubled up on on the
second place score
so maybe they're just like let's just
let's just have some fun tonight
and just just get them
all right that that if i if i if i was
oh this is a oh okay okay so jd
is playing with it with the black piece
so he is protecting
i would be very very excited if
when after you know you get a night sack
that the next move
is followed up with uh night night back
but
there goes a it's a trade
so okay so maybe he had he had good
ideas there
so now the knight is on the attack maybe
he can sack it again
maybe get this queen in see what's going
on here
board one action enterprise against
edward jones
enterprise big daddy jazz 64 is playing
with the white pieces against jd
on board one
all right let's see let's see let's see
what a king taker's up to
here he actually he won his first game
for uh
for edward jones
let me mark that on the list
here's some rough standings okay so
these are
unofficial standings take them with a
grain of salt
but so far bear has four
i expect the big things from bear
actually today
ascension has three merits one
ex express scripts one my unofficial
has three with um
for edward jones and wwt at least has
one with
the david chopin uh victory
so we'll be updating uh this the uh
we'll
cue everybody in on the standings uh
going into uh round two we'll update the
standings for you
all right this
looks like uh maybe swap the board one
for merits is going to get his uh
his revenge against us essentia
yeah he's up a queen so so we don't want
to pencil in anything yet but
marist might be getting on the board
with a point they of course are second
place so far
in the uh corporate chess league yeah
just grab get another queen yep
all right let's check in on david
chopin's game it looks like he is
winning he is playing with the black
pieces
and it looks like he is up a rook but
but hey
you know you got to keep fighting
especially in team events you got to
just keep going
no no stopping yourself you know you
have a an advantage with this
pawn just try try to get him but now he
has uh
pinned the queen so it so he's demanding
a queen trade
and he's also attacking the rook so he's
got to just
take it oh so oh no
no this is complicated
i don't know what to do do you take the
rook
no you don't take the rook you've got to
take the queen you have to take the
queen here if you take the rook he's
going to take and get a queen
and then rook takes queen takes so david
should be able to just figure this out
pretty easy
just take the queen check and then move
work the b8
this allows bishop to f4 now though
so you know that's right so
let's let's see how this just plays out
but even if you have to trade your rook
for the uh
for the bishop and the pawn you'll still
be okay
so so david plays for wwt against
doherty this is their board twos
so let's see if if this guy can put the
pressure on with bishop to f4
okay he gets out of the pin but now you
can you can probably take the rook here
right
i would just take the rook
and that that is on the board now
white can either play his bishop f4
maneuver
or maybe even take because it takes back
he'll take the take the knight and maybe
you could try for
just a perpetual check somehow some way
good luck but it's a try it's a try
oh instead he plays his bishop to d2
and uh he got gobbled up so it looks
like david's gonna have a nice victory
and he's also threatening now rook
to d3 pinning the the rook to the queen
so he gave he gave it he gave it a ride
with this pawn
but didn't come through
so let's check back in on alex corford
he's not having as easy time as he had
this is the current live position in
this game
so it looks like alex's rook is under
attack so he attacks
the other rook instead of just playing
rook here rick you do not want to play
rick c1 because
uh because he's got this nifty uh bishop
takes
e3 check maneuver and then he could
gobble up the rook
so maybe alex wants to get his rook on
d1
assuming this rook moves all right so
i'm thinking it's going to be rook a to
d1
i wonder why he didn't just take
rook takes e3 or maybe he wants to he
maybe he's saving that he may be saving
the chuck
interesting
oh and the bishop protects the pawn but
he still has
three three guys on it and now he still
can eat the rook
too interesting
this is anybody's game alex corford the
founder
of the corporate chess league playing
against
enterprise
moneyballing is plus two on the
scoreboard but
the evaluation has him up by about eight
points so i don't know which one you
trust the evaluation or the actual
scoreboard
so this is game and 10 no delay no
increment so
okay well there's the check
alex takes back so how is he going to
take the bishop
with the rook work attacks the queen
queen attacks the rook so you can't take
this rook or else
well your one your night pilot gets
trapped and two you're going to lose
this rook
so moneyballin has got to be careful in
this position
check back on a king takers game
oh let's check out the the conclusion of
jd's game
that was the one where uh he took
on on f7 early
jd's opponent from uh enterprise
so let's see if he got to generate any
kind of attack okay he got his knight up
king retreats to safety
and he gave him a check
big check and up
and a back row checkmate good job jd
getting the win for edward jones all
right
so let's get back to alex's game he's
got 90 seconds left
so that that's what i consider the
danger zone once you get under that 90
seconds
you really got to think all right he's
trying to
tell the queen to get out of here
so let's see if he offers him a queen
trade with queen to
g3
he's also got dreams of knight takes
check
you don't want to play knight takes
check just yet
because your queen is under attack
so how is moneyballing gonna
gonna gonna deal with this uh these are
chess.com
blitz ratings they can be quite
deceptive
uh because some people might not play
too often on chess.com
they might just play in the corporate
chess league events
and and a lot of times you can you can
build up your rating by playing the same
opponent over and over and over
and maybe beating them you know five six
times in a row
and getting a hundred points or vice
versa so
they're very deceptive so moneyballing
is uh
money balance rating is 1010 and alex is
1600.
a solid 1600.
so let's see if he can convert the win
if i was alex all i'd be thinking about
is just do not lose on time and
and and try to generate as much as you
can now he's got a pass pawn
so uh perhaps alex
okay he's going to protect it i probably
would have gone for
well maybe i would have gone for more
rook activity
but hang on hang on to what you got
oh this king can't really get and this
knight is doing a great job of keeping
this
this king at bay the king cannot break
in
so every time you can pre-move on
chess.com
that's basically whoa
oh wow
so oh a big check coming for alex and
that's going to be all she wrote it's
all right
alex he generated a pass pawn and he got
it through
unlike in the in the previous game we
saw with that b-pawn
so this is 35 seconds and then he's got
he can just bring his king up in the up
unstoppable mate
so alex comes up big for
edward jones
now we do have a late game going on
between uh the board ones
of ascension and express scripts
kyqz is making his first appearance in
the corporate chess league
playing against express scripts board
one
so we might not be able to take our ten
minute break
if we got this game still going if if
this game is exciting as it's all built
up to be
up to you okay well maybe well
we'll see let's just see how this uh
this game proceeds
and let's take a good look at the end of
king taker's game too
maybe king taker can get the uh best
prize award like he did last
month he played a heck of a game he
avoided a maiden two
and ended up running his opponent out of
time
so it was it was everybody was
threatening the checkmates it was it was
a very exciting match
so let's see how king taker's doing king
taker of course is playing for uh
edward jones against enterprise
put alex's big win on so uh
edward jones is at least up four
oh right now oh and
jd also won so that that that's five
and five should clinch the match so
edward jones gets that bonus 20 grand
three points and they're once again
right on the way of winning this event
and in the next round edward jones
is paired up against merits who is in
second place
going into this uh this event
with 101 grand prix points so that
should be a
a good match so they're going to be
they're going to be tested
that's for sure all right so what is
going on so
king taker is down on time he's playing
with the black pieces
according to the computer he has plus
two
points
he's got more kingside pawns
but i think they like white's activity
more i'm almost tempted just to turn off
the evaluation
so white white is threatening checkmate
right now
so got to be careful got to be careful
that's one way to stop it a little
interference so
thread another uh check with rook to h3
i would have i would assume that he just
takes it
oh the fork but now he can just play
rick takes check obviously i mean that's
got to be played
and now he's oh it's not checkmate
though it's not sure
oh he's got dreams of
oh he takes the bishop and it looks like
uh
it looks like enterprise will get on the
board
and they they need to get some uh some
grand prix points here
but here comes a check
i would just consolidate here with queen
queen check
rook check king moves bishop takes king
takes and then just
mark this ways works fine maybe maybe he
just wants checkmate
maybe he just wants to show off his
skill and get get a check mate here
there's a check i do not see a mate i
mean rook to f3 looks very tempting here
because the queen is not doing much for
the defense here
so king to g7 has to be played
and then what about rook to f3 then
or not rook f3 uh
rick the f7 check
and he ran out of the chicks
well unless he wants to trade queens i
mean that would be the simplest way to
win
and that way you can prevent any kind of
a perpetual check or any kind of
nonsense okay so he's threatening mate
uh queen to g8 oh here comes the check
oh he's going for the perpetual here it
comes here
that king taker you never give up king
taker that's what i like about this guy
it could be the sky could be falling but
he he gets the resources to uh
to keep the game moving
oh
did that guy just
oh king taker can't take her
king taker had his chance
wow but he got the checkmate that he
always wanted
instead of just training off the queens
i eliminated all counter play
he wanted that checkmate he wanted and
he got it
but not without
oh king take or you could
could have bounced back
wow what a game so okay so let's see uh
we have one more game going
oh it looks like uh
kyqz for ascension ascension's board one
is living up to his billing this
pre-game billing that
that he was going to he was going to
really help help
ascension get into that uh
fourth spot and and they have a heck of
a game against uh
wwt in round
two so the wwe obviously has the third
spot going into this
into this uh match into this
installment and so it
it's all in their hands they can take
take their spot
there's actually five games still in
progress five games okay
do we have anybody else to follow here
yeah not sure that's coming from nick
though
uh yeah can you can you text nick or ask
him so we can get another game
rolling here
there are some more games in progress
actually it sounds like there's five
games in progress though so
so much to uh much to consider here
anyway
uh yeah yeah we haven't really
checked up on this ascension express
scripts uh
match do we have any uh updated scores
from nick risco
nick riscoe is our excellent uh
tournament director of the corporate
chess league
he gets it all all running and going we
did actually want to start
about before we want to start around
seven o'clock
round two so hopefully we can get get it
started
so yeah there's about what 11 minutes
left in this match so these are
unofficial up-to-date standings tonight
uh
bear has eight they brought the most
people
so that was smart of them they bought
seven total
wwt right behind with seven edward jones
has
seven an ascension
has clinched the match they needed
they needed what five and a half out of
the ten
and they got the six so bear wwt
edward jones and ascension all got the
bonus 20 points so
really add 28 to bear 27
for wwt and edward jones and 26
for ascension followed by
the rest so very interesting
so i was expecting a bear to come up big
and uh and they didn't disappoint
nick says those scores are very very uh
accurate and there's only
three games left now okay oh yeah and
nick risco says yeah you can you can
take it to the bank so if nick risco
says it
we're very lucky to have him on the
corporate chess league team that's for
sure
making all the nice spreadsheets and
getting getting get it rolling
and a shout out to uh of course alex
corford the founder
uh our development managers lauren
stewart
and uh ryan chester club manager as well
ranchester
and of course uh tara meyer making the
initial spreadsheet
that me and nicholas can base the
pairings off of so
it's a team effort at the corporate
chess league and of course we couldn't
do it without these great eight
corporations playing today
and we'll run down the the round two
matchups that will start uh sometime
a little bit probably after seven are
right around seven when nicholas risco
gives the word we'll have ascension
against wwt
bear against express scripts doherty
against enterprise
and merits against edward jones so
merits trying to play spoiler for the
rest of the uh
the league here can edward jones but
even if edward jones
even if they would win every single game
they still might not win bear bears
bring in the numbers so if bear wins out
there's nothing edward jones can do
bear would take the top prize tonight
all right so let's see what is going on
in this game oh white has
a past pawn here but it's got a long way
to go
but he's got this extra bishop but you
know you just got to keep
keep playing as uh alex got he got his
pass pawn through
so yeah just keep pushing the pawn i
like it
so kyqz has got to act quick his pawn is
rolling
the last two moves he's gotten four
and i get this other rook behind the
pawn that's what uh white
community has to do that yeah and that's
what he plays good
this is the last game so we we we will
be able to
as build right we will get the next
round started
before seven most likely whenever nick
risco says the ward
so we will be taking a 10 minute break
at the conclusion of this game
and then we'll be right back at it with
the official
up-to-date standings and the match-ups
for uh and all the exciting games for
round two
what is going on is he going to be able
to get this pawn
through why did he go
back to g3
oh okay so he was afraid of
he was really afraid of rook takes and
then he's got
discovered checks so that that makes a
lot of sense
oh he gave up his so he attacks
the bishop and he lets
them have it
interesting that pawn that pawn
those past pawns that was the theme of
of the last installment of as well of
the court
protest league because you never want to
resign in a team event
so you actually have to play to
checkmate and usually the way
to get the checkmate is to get a pass
pawn and get the win
you convert the passer into a win
so let's see if kyqz
can take home this full point
so this rook is really tied to this pawn
interesting
are you going to give him a check he
does give him a check
are king's moving up oh he's not afraid
of g4 he's not afraid of g4 check
because of a
on passant a very tricky move in chess
big check
another check so this game could go the
distance
maybe he's just going to run kamuni out
of time he does not want to be checked
so he goes up there
okay so now he's threatening rook to e3
check he might as well play it
hey mike yes sir i just got word that
edward jones has
gotten their fifth player whatever that
means
maybe they didn't have five before i
don't know i'm just the messenger
all right edward jones has five players
tonight just just
this just as i thought they had
five
who knows
can they really bring a fifth player in
they'll do anything
they'll do anything they do not want to
lose
they do not want they saw a bear brought
seven players so they're like
we gotta we gotta go we got we gotta
so one we have one game one game going
currently
and then we'll be taking a 10-minute
break from the broadcast we'll come back
with all
all the live standings and we'll see if
edward jones can
can do it again
i wonder if if this i wonder if they're
just gonna
run uh when this guy out of time
remember yeah uh with with the pre moves
you do lose a tenth of a second every
time you make a pre-move so
and of course chess.com will just call
this game
if there's 50 moves without a pawn move
or a capture
so if they just dance around for for uh
50 times
chest.com will just call it
automatically there it is
drop oh and also a threefold repetition
gets it
so a good a good draw for the board ones
we will take a 10 minute break we'll be
right back with uh
round two enjoy
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering
24 weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scolaska tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
[Music]
my name is alex kurford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team captain
of our deborah jones test team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity
for companies around the st louis area
and hopefully one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility
of chess that we have here in st louis
and
we decided to get a tournament around
that to where
companies can play one another compete
in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for a wide variety of
people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short-term intermediate steps can
translate into
all types of different areas of life
ever jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can have some
fun camaraderie with other companies
that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
and again just be able to come and
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube
and twitch channels we're also holding
tournaments and private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
[Music]
my name is alex kirford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team captain
of our trevor jones test team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity
for companies around the st louis area
and hopefully one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility
of chess that we have here in st louis
and
we decided to get a tournament around
that to where
companies can play one another compete
in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for a wide variety of
people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short-term intermediate steps can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
ever jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can have some
fun camaraderie with other companies
that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
and again just be able to come and
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube
and twitch channels we're also holding
tournaments and private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms scholastica
tournaments and scouts bsa merit badge
workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
[Music]
my name is alex curford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team captain
of our deborah jones test team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity
for companies around the st louis area
and hopefully one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility
of chess that we have here in st louis
and
we decided to get a tournament around
that
to where companies can play one another
compete in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for a wide variety of
people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short-term intermediate steps can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
everett jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
and again just be able to come and
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the fourth installment
out of six of the corporate
just leading and thank you to danny
machuca for that awesome graphic
and thank you for everybody that's
watching at home on youtube
and uh we got about 80 people watching
thank you for uh
joining us if you don't know what this
is this is the corporate chess league
this is the
third season of the uh
of the great uh of the great event uh
alex crawford he thought it up and we
put it into reality
so thank you for joining us we have some
exciting matchups tonight
in round two and it's a double round so
they'll be playing their same opponent
with the white pieces and the black
pieces
and right off the bat here we go
you want to show the uh the standings so
this is the standings after round one
you get an additional 20 points for
winning your match
and you get one point every time you
actually win a game
or half if you draw so bear who brought
seven players tonight they they got
they got the the destiny in their hands
29
points 29 grand pre-points
followed by wwt edward jones
edward jones is the back-to-back
champion of the league
they have never lost a match
ever so so today could be the day
and then they got ascension is right
behind they're still in the hunt with 26
and a half
and they are all playing to get into the
final four
on december 17th so you have to be in
the top four
in the overall grand prix standings
which edward jones is of course
leading with 188 and a half points going
into this
into this match so so the matchups for
round two
ascension will be playing wwt so a huge
match
bear is playing express scripts
so if fair wins every game they'll
they'll end up on top tonight
doherty is playing enterprise so
somebody will have a
an additional 20 points after that match
unless it goes to a draw
and then merits is playing edward jones
merits going
into into today's action was in second
place with 101
grand prix points so hopefully everybody
is up to date
with what's going on and we can just
dive into the action let's check out uh
alex corford's game
uh he is playing i am rounder
unfortunately that game got aborted but
they'll they'll get it they'll get it
sorted out
okay here it is here's the here's the
real match between i am rounder
and alex gorford alex corford is of
course playing for
edward jones on
board number two against i am rounder
merits is bored too so let's see what is
going on
it looks like even material they've just
traded upon
no fireworks yet in that one let's see
if see if we got
some fireworks here
and we still have to figure out the best
game prize too so a lot of pressure on
me tonight
i i will select the best game price
so let's check it out
yeah alex alex got that past pawn
through
in the uh in the in the well in the
second
round of match number one so maybe let's
check out what david's up to here
he is currently plus 14 and he won by
resignation
so that's a one win
for wwt right off the bat
see if it gives them a check here i i
can't resist that check
bishop to b5 check you just got to do it
see if i can get the best guesser
oh it must have been a mouse slip maybe
maybe he wanted to play the check
all right so
all right let's let's go around the
board here and get
see what else is going on
oh yeah the chess expert tonight
essentia
let's see he's playing with bear so bear
bear really
brought their a game tonight they
brought the most players
which gives them an advantage because
every game is worth
one point so the more players you have
the more more chances you have to
accumulate points
so this is a huge game the board won
against
express scripts number one board
so what is going on in this one yeah the
time control for all these matches are
game and 10
no delay no increment so lots on the
line tonight
you got grand prix points and and four
teams
are what within uh two and a half points
of each other once again bears got 29
points
wwt 28 edward jones 27
and ascension with 26 and a half so
this is about as close as it's it's ever
been four teams
in uh in contention to win it
and will edward jones not
be crowned a champion of of an in
of an evidence of an installment
i don't know it would be amazing this
this could be a historic
night in the corporate chess league
of course it all culminates in the final
four
we will be having another one of uh
another uh
the fifth installment so this these are
the the standings going in
to uh into tonight's to get into the
final four of course you want to be on
the left side of the screen so edward
jones has accumulated 188 and a half
points because you know
they win every game they win every match
merits right behind with 101
but they have a tough match against
edward jones tonight
and then wwt with 83
enterprise will they hold on to that
78 and a half the fourth spot tonight
ascension with 72 and a half so they
yeah if they beat a
wwt they'll be sitting
on that side and then bear
big things for bear if bear can beat
express scripts tonight
they're going to accumulate a bunch of
points and maybe i mean
this whole this whole thing could shift
tonight
bear i think has an opportunity
to get about 60 points tonight going
into the match and
and they did very well
so let's get back to the actions here
let's see uh let's see
let's see what uh alex crawford is up to
against uh
i guess i am rounder
and then we had essentia
playing for bear
it looks like they have communi
express scripts number one board plus
two
on the scoreboard this is a
big big game for bear
he's pushing those pawns over there get
the queen side rolling
i like it
so now what's he going to do is he going
to push the pawn or take the pawn he's
going gonna push it
so he's only two away from becoming a
queen let's see if it ever happens
it's gonna be tough but stranger things
have happened as we saw in the
in the league today
it always comes down to those past pawns
alright let's check out this game
it looks like uh
white is going to win
the wizzy up by two touchdowns
and he is playing for doherty
against enterprise
he's going for that stalemate but i
don't think he's going to get it as he's
going to have checkmate
in one move
so that's going to be a win for doherty
enterprise of course left home uh all
their uh
their three-headed monster as hell so
yeah that they
they were kind of up against it tonight
and of course they had to get played
against edward jones in the first round
too so that's a tough tough matches for
them
all right let's check out uh speaking of
enterprise uh big daddy jazz 64. their
number one board tonight
see how he's doing so he's he's picking
up the slack
for board one
and uh it looks like he's going to to
get the win here
lots of things going on here
his rook is being attacked by the bishop
so he's just got to ask himself how does
he want to deal with this or
does he even want to deal with it he
probably does want to deal with it
but he's only got three minutes to go
the computer
has a plus six and with the evaluation
at negative 15
so but the pressure is on he's under
three minutes the time control once
again is game 10 no delay no increment
so
you got you gotta you gotta move
but where to move
oh the counter attack
very interesting so i would i would just
take it right
that's my guess
and then i'd be only plus five but the
computer does not like that move
on my part what am i missing if he takes
what am i missing
yeah i'm missing something
i'm missing something what is wrong with
taking that pawn
because you can't not take back
all right well let's i just said he
couldn't take back
yeah you can't take back because of
queen takes and that's on the board
oh so so he went from a plus
plus six now he's just plus one
he still has an advantage but it's not
as big as it once was
interesting let's as let's actually look
at the computer
why didn't it like pawn takes
pawn can he see it can he see the
evaluation
nope
nope i can't say it well well your guess
is as good as mine
why the computer did not like that move
but all right life goes on though
let's see if uh if he can get get the
win anyway
whedon 80 defeated oak avenue
whedon 80 is playing for wwt so
so right now at least wwt is up two
nothing i have against ascension of
course both of those teams are playing
for first place
tonight
david chopin a regular at the friday
action quads
see how he's doing
well the position says the positions
equal oh oh watch out
this is this is this is a this is
dangerous
he's trying to get get rid of that
knight and go for the queen takes
check unfortunately it won't be
checkmate because after king f8
he can play the check but then the
knight hops in
but then you got the bishop to h7
attacking the
pinned piece of the knight so it could
be dangerous
for david here let's see how he deals
with this threat
does he just calmly play g6 knight g6
okay
play a little interference
all right so they do automatic rematches
when when the games have concluded so
david got him in the first round
see how he does in the second
so he dealt with that thread that's
smart so let's go back
let's see what oak avenue
is up to
oak avenue is playing for ascension he
lost the first round of weed in
80. but it looks like he's
doing pretty well
well maybe not maybe not
we'll see we'll see how this goes
if i'm wee nady i just want to get
castle i'll play bishop the d
well maybe maybe get out of the pin
first
oh check okay so he forces the queen
trades
well he wants to trade like that
which is interesting so now he could
play maybe bishop to uh b4 here
all right he just takes it gets on with
the show
oh maybe he can take the pawn now huh
does he dare does he dare i would dare
first throw in a check first i like it i
like there's nothing wrong with that now
you're more away from castling
and now attack the pin piece again
knight takes e4
can he see it or is it even good
you tell me big game big game in this
worldwide technologies against ascension
matchup
we didn't play for wwt
and he does play this is the live
position or maybe i'll be the top
guesser
so now it looks like bishop d2 is
probably
forced
or else you're going to lose your pawn
and your rook to this bishop because
knight takes knight pawn takes bishop
takes
the fork attacking the king and the rook
and then it's dangerous so bishop d2 has
to be played
and then knight takes d2 i know this
probably isn't oh
he could maybe play knight to e2 here
maybe that's what he's going to play
instead that looks a little
safer
let's see let's see how he deals with
this pin and then we'll go to uh
to another game here and we do have
another result on the board
that 92 is played okay good job and we
do have a result a draw
by insufficient material
that was uh the enterprise
and doherty match up so doherty
getting some points this this round as
is enterprise so half half
for the first round and now yeah they
just go right into the rematch
all right so this is the big board one
match-up for bear
against kamuni it looks like kamuni is
plus six on the scoreboard
but that can be very deceptive
he just took a pawn
so what is going on here white
has
white has an extra piece here
or does he is
it looks like white's got a lot of stuff
going and he's got that past pawn he
just wants that queen
so bishop g7 has got to be played
so what you just move your knight
somewhere
oh maybe knight to e8 that looks good
see if we can find knight e8
oh 98 he just played his bishop to f8 so
it wasn't as good as it was billed
well maybe oh he's attacking attack he
keep attacking that knight and keep
attacking
now you can get a queen and it looks
like
kamuni will take it
and kamuni is express scripts board one
so bear bear had the destiny in their
hands
because they have 29 uh points right now
in in this installment of the corporate
chess league a wwt right behind with 28
edward jones with 27 and ascension with
26 and a half so it's anybody's game
right now
with uh you know trying to get the
standings
so oh he got his knight to uh he's very
greedy
he he does not want to trade that pawn
for that bishop and that's going to be
it
there you go okay yeah oh so these are
the
the most live standings then i mean
these these are being updated throughout
the night
throughout this round so it looks like
bears still holding on
with or without this win lose or draw
which it looks like it's going to be a
loss
edward jones with their fifth player
now has 32. they they added
they had a a secret sub at that at the
end
of uh round one just because they they
do not like to lose i mean they've that
i mean
as i said they've won everything we've
been doing this for two and a half years
now two and a half seasons
they've won every single match one did
come down to to
the armageddon match and uh alex corfer
came through big against enterprises
board one
and so he won that that installment and
of course they won the final four
championship last year to go
back-to-back champions
and they got their name on a very nice
uh wooden board
and that's what they're playing for
tonight more grand prix points
to get into that final four on december
17th and it all just resets the zero
zero zero and then you have to win on
the final four
so yeah like oh yep all right he won by
resignation so
add a point to uh to express scripts
so one less point that bear can get to
try to win first place
but they're right back at it
and this time essentia has uh the white
pieces
all right kamuni taking it to him with
queen to f6
yeah yep okay so he was a threatening
bishop to g5 but he can't
not allow it so now he's playing yep so
this guy's
like don't attack my queen i'm gonna
bring my queen out early but i'm not
gonna let you attack it
i like his strategy i like it i like it
this could be best game
the best game prize will be awarded
we'll have the award ceremony somewhere
before 8 o'clock that's that's all i can
guarantee right
we we got some time pressure here let's
watch some time pressure here
kyqz he plays uh board one for ascension
has a monster lead here
oh but he's got the passer he's got the
passer
smart it's just yeah you've seen it time
and time again just just
just get it while you can good job
now you can have dreams of checkmate
just take it
and blend that pawn up right now we're
in the other pawn up
good keep going
oh dream's a stalemate oh
oh this would be a stalemate this would
be a stalemate if he gets a queen
too smart
just keep holding on just try to get
that stalemate somehow some way
oh does he get the queen oh he just
takes the bishop for the win
good job good job k1
kyqz with the win over a chess
expert kyqz the number one board
of ascension living up to his uh
his reputation ascension said they got a
great guy on board one and they
just he just knocked off a a
chest.com blitz expert
those are the ratings we're using
tonight chess.com blitz ratings
and they're off with the second match
you know commerceco said that chess.com
has just changed game
intend to wrap it it's considered rapid
now
when did that happen i don't know that's
crazy isn't it
that's very disappointing so chess.com
now considers gaming 10
a rapid rating
but this was paired with the blitz rate
as it should be
all right well the good people over at
chess.com i cannot complain
as uh they are they run the pro
chess league which has nothing to do
with the corporate chess league
but my i i'm very fortunate i get to
manage i'm the team manager of the st
louis archbishops we were supposed to go
to chess party 2020 in norway
way back in may i even bought a passport
and then oh no it's going to be
september don't worry september you were
going to norway
no such luck so we're having it online
but but great and i'm going to announce
it tonight i don't care if
armenia's watching or montreal
or who we're going to be playing in in
the final four
uh well pretty soon september 25th
uh the china pandas uh we we are going
to play
fabiano dominguez wesley cell
and jeffrey zhang and jeffrey zhong i
don't know if you've been following
uh this online chess he has been uh
ramping up his game extremely i mean he
was great
i mean obviously it was a grand master
in
2015 he got his grandmaster title right
here in the st louis chess club
but uh he's he's really excelled even
even more so since then so we're so
happy to have him on board for
so expect big things from the uh st
louis archbishops and maybe we'll win
20 000 so watch that friday september
25th
uh that game time will be a roughly
around 9
45 a.m usa central time all right enough
about that
and uh david chopin uh
loses to
mr ragon so mr ragon got his
got his rematch got his revenge
and so ascension's nick ragone
got a point for his team so it's still
anybody's game
bear wwt edward jones ascension
they're all in the mix they're all in
the mix
let's check out uh alex corford's game
he got a win
for edward jones the founder of the
corporate chess league in in round
number one
so how is he doing this time around
so oh so he's got two rooks you'd much
rather have
the two bishops in the past pawn than
just this lone
rook
but maybe maybe alex can do something
with these pawns get these guys rolling
somehow some way
b6 a5 and try to generate some kind of
offense
or fork the bishops even better
uh-oh
man oh man oh man so
so dreams of counter attack oh dreams of
a counter attack will
work possibly bishop here
b6 okay but then bishop
to d3
and that might save the day
it might save the day because then
you're protecting bishop d3 and then
once he moves that rook
then you move your bishop back to
e1 and just get him safe so that rook is
protecting all the bishops and then you
can just
reassess from there
so let's see if well yeah you cannot
play
bishop here right now wow and i am
runner's having some difficulty
figuring out what to do here
it's not an easy escape but i think he
does have a remedy
if he so chooses
and maybe maybe even bishop here is
better than than here uh
in the second move so bishop a5 has to
be played
and while
so he just takes so alex
has a monster
a monster lead in this game now
but he does it lead in time that is
and so i think that's what it's all
going to come down to here
so he needs to protect this pawn
with rook to e1 here and then just
just try to bust through here okay rick
e1 is played on the board this is a huge
game for edward jones
because even if they win the match and
get that 20 points
they need to accumulate a lot of points
to catch up to bear
who brought seven players and edward
jones of course
has five so we'll see how it all plays
out here
and maybe after this match we can get
some updated standings from
nick risco as well so these are this
these are the most up-to-date standings
okay
bear has 34. so if edward jones would
win this game
they would be tied with bear at 34.
and unfortunately we cannot have an
armageddon match
shucks so
it would be a tie it would be the first
tie in corporate chest league history
but but we still have plenty of games
outstanding so
so let's not get ahead of ourselves
anyway just because they're tied at 34
doesn't mean uh that's it there's still
some outstanding games
so he's going for it here he's trying to
get this deep on through
or this he pawn through but alex is not
going to let him do that
rook f6 here rook f6 by alex and that
should clinch the game
or maybe or maybe well well maybe maybe
he was thinking rook e8
uh-oh oh just take the bishop just take
the bishop you have to take the bishop
here
no doubt about it no doubt about it and
then
and then alex can just run him right out
of time
just right out of time
and any and he theoretically have an
extra pawn too so alex has got to play
rook takes c6 here
well i don't even know if that works
because then you still got the rook
check
because he just ignores you and plays
the rook check but then you play king f7
ugh this is tough maybe you just have to
take this pawn now
okay so he plays rick takes c6 rook
check is is gonna come on the way
maybe he can just check him to death too
because there's no delay no increment
oh at first he plays the check first he
places so he did not take
he plays the check first
what is he gonna do just take the pawn
alex
you want to check him some more give him
some checks
now you don't want to get checkmated
here
uh oh uh oh uh oh so now
rook to e8 is threatening checkmate here
oh now you can't even take the pawn on
uh
on d the d pawn so these this has been
the theme of the night these
past pawns they're so devious but he's
only got 16 seconds so he takes the pawn
oh
he took the pawn and so that would have
been checkmate
instead he takes the pawn unfortunately
for alex he can't really
do much to stop this checkmate he's got
to play rook to g5 now
and then just try to run him out of time
there it is
and now king f7
rook back when you see a mate
take the mate
oh he missed he missed a big
check so now if he gets rid of the pawn
uh it it'll just be a draw so
i am rounder has the draw in his hand
but it's going to be very tough to
checkmate him
every time you pre-move it's a tenth of
a second gone
draw by stalemate oh
and that could be the half point that
that that does it
either way wow
so what what a game
so in this position
so even if you take the bishop as i was
recommending
rook takes check king f7
and then he just moves the rook and then
you can't stop him from getting
getting a queen that was a fun one
though
that was a fun one so so the most
up-to-date standings that i have then
is uh bear still holding on by a half
point
well here's what oh oh but
but edward jones probably got another
victory somewhere along the lines
so alex got him up to 33 and a half
and then somebody else for edward jones
you know that's a team
pick pick up your teammates that's
that's how you that's how you do it
maybe the fifth guy got in there without
the point so they go
34 and a half points bare
right behind with 34 ascension and wwt
right behind right behind
but that's that's going to be a tough
one for either of those
it looks like it's a two-horse race
right now between bear and edward jones
wow okay let's let's get to uh let's get
to us
to uh so we have some late results then
um
five games are left we have uh the
the board one for bear and express
scripts
bear is playing for bear is essentia
playing for express grips is communi
but this
i wonder if this is an actual uh
i i mean this should be a real game
because i'm thinking
that you know they already played way
earlier
today so this might not actually be
part of the corporate chess league i'll
have to check on that they might just be
playing for fun right now
but i don't know if they would really do
that
but who knows because it doesn't say
that uh
oh see ascension is not playing um okay
this is just
essential is just playing a fun game
right now so this has nothing to do with
the corporate chess league
all right so let's move on two games
left
two games left and then we will have a
and it's coming down to the wire here
kyqz ascensions
tap board against against wwt's
top man
and we got to figure out the game of the
day
game of the day hopefully this one will
have a fireworks and uh
see a win
thank you once again all the youtube uh
youtube guys following us
hopefully we'll do this again october
15th so join us then
live let us know what you think in the
comments i'm sure you will
but that's why we love it that's why we
love it
he got a queen
so white wins by checkmate so uh
chalk up another win for ascension
so that guy that guy really came to play
today
for our ascension ascension has a new
board one so let's see if they
if they got into the final four i think
we're gonna have a big shake up
in the uh in the final four standings
when it's all said and done
we'll do some quick math and uh
and wrap this one up momentarily here
you want to take a quick break ben simon
yeah we'll take a
few minutes to tabulate everything okay
yeah so yeah we will take about a five
to a seven minute break we'll get the
game of the day
and we'll get uh we'll see we'll see who
won between bear and edward jones
and then we'll see uh the the whole
final four standing sound good sounds
good
all right
oh you want cheers go now as good as
time as any
no okay
all right we'll be right back after this
at the corp just look
my name is alex kurford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team captain
of our trevor jones test team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity for companies
around the st louis area and hopefully
one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility
of chess that we have here in st louis
and
we decided to get a tournament around
that to where
companies can play one another compete
in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well chess is important
for a wide variety of people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short-term intermediate steps can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
ever jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can have some
fun camaraderie with other companies
that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
and again just be able to come and
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
my name is alex curford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team captain
of our journeys test team the corporate
chess league
is an opportunity for companies around
the st
louis area and hopefully one day beyond
to
come and compete at a world-class
facility
of chess that we have here in st louis
and
we decided to get a tournament around
where companies can play one another
compete in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for a wide variety of
people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short-term intermediate steps can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
ever jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that were associated with
it looks like they're done well as a way
to for ourselves
to populate some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
no it looks like at everyone
top class facility and have some fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on we
are currently offering 24 weekly classes
online through our youtube and twitch
channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative
digital our scholastic outreach
continues with virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
my name is alex curford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team captain
of our giver jones test team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity
for companies around the st louis area
hopefully one day beyond to come and
compete at a
world-class facility of chess that we
have here in st
louis and we decided to
get a tournament around that to where
companies can play one another
compete in a friendly a competitive way
and enjoy each other's company as well
chess is important
for a wide variety of people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short term intermediate steps can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
ever jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
and again just be able to come and
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i want to compare numbers with you since
2009 our mission has always been to
teach and promote the value
chess brings to our community in these
times of social distancing it's more
important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on we
are currently offering 24 weekly classes
online through our youtube
and twitch channels we're also holding
tournaments and private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts psa
mayor bedford you're probably right
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
yeah but it's express scripts they
scored 30 and a half it says
well it says 30 and a half
my name is alex curford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones
of our giver jones test team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity for companies
around the st louis area and hopefully
one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility
of chess that we have here in st louis
and
we decided to get a tournament around
that to where
companies can play one another compete
in a friendly
a competitive way and enjoy each other's
company as well
chess is important for a wide variety of
people
because it helps with your decision
making it will help with your problem
solving
being able to think long term and have
short term intermediate steps can
translate into all types of different
areas of life
everett jones chose to compete in the
corporate chess league
as a way that we can
have some fun camaraderie with other
companies that we're associated with
as well as a way to for ourselves be
able to
build some some teamwork aspects as we
have as a company
and again just be able to come and
participate at a top class facility and
have some fun
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value
chess brings to our community in these
times of social distancing it's more
important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
89 and a half
[Music]
46.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is alex curford i'm a financial
advisor at edward jones and team
captain of our trevor jones test team
the corporate chess league is an
opportunity
for companies around the st louis area
and hopefully one day beyond
to come and compete at a world-class
facility of
chess that we have here in st louis and
we decided to
get a tournament around that to where
companies can play one another
compete in a friendly a competitive way
and enjoy each other's company as well
chess is important
welcome back to the corporate chess
league this was the
fourth installment out of six to get to
the final four
and here are the final standings for
tonight
once again it was it was as tough as
it's ever been for edward jones
and they'll they'll surely admit it and
uh but they came out on top
55 and a half points
grand prix points added to the
collection
and then right behind him was ascension
who had a tough match against
wwe
t in the last round but but persevered
and they finished second place with 52
and a half points bear
came strong they came with numbers and
they were so close
to to you know ultimately winning it
but they fell to express scripts and
they finished with 34 points
wwt got 32 express scripts
30 and a half with with that win against
bear doherty
27 and a half and then rounding out is
enterprise with four and a half and
merits with two and a half points
so now the big question is
how does that shape the grand prix
points so after four of the six events
edward jones keeps rolling 244 wwt
is not in second place ascension is now
in second place
125 points they came in as the fifth
seed
but vaulted their way to second place
wwt
held strong they they came in as the
third seed they held their spot
merits 103 and a half
falling from second to fourth but
holding on by just an edge against
bear who has now they vaulted their way
up a notch
but still outside looking in to get into
that final four they have 102
points express scripts right behind with
89 and a half
enterprise fell out of the final four
rotation
they have 83 and doherty has 46
points with their win now who got
the game of the day none other than
knock on wood edward jones's first
board he uh big daddy jazz 64.
he he came with the attack in uh
game two but knock on wood jd
was able to uh to counter it and
get get get the big win so
congratulations to jd and
congratulations once again to edward
jones for another
first place finish join us october 15th
for
the fifth installment the penultimate
installment of the regular season of
2020.
good night
[Music]
you